Hello, this is Jin from Next Level
Commander and today I present to you the
biggest commander deck of all time. For
reference, the average Aldrazi decks
don't usually go higher than 4.5 for
average mana value. Meanwhile, Gashath
dinosaurs fall just below 3.5. That is
weak because the average mana value of
our big deck is a whopping 6.048.
In this monstrosity, we are powering
with just 10 lands technically. How does
that work? Well, it's like going to the
most luxurious restaurants, but only
ordering water. Using the most expensive
makeup, but it's just free samples. Fake
it till you make it. This is basically
scornful egotist, but an entire deck.
Vanity is the game we're playing today.
We get to use all these high-end
creatures like avatar of wo, but only
when it's on sale. We attend the most
prestigious schools, but can't afford
the classes. Now, another cornerstone of
the faking till making is looking very
busy, but not accomplishing much. Who
says magic doesn't teach real life
skills? Starting turn one, we'll be
tapping our lands, shuffling our decks,
yelling in response, pulling our cards
in and out of their sleeves just to hit
our land drops in the early game. And
trust me, you will usually get there,
but it's a struggle. You have to figure
out which colors you need now and which
ones you may need in the next few turns.
I guess I just enjoy decks that work
against you. But you're not like me. You
don't hate yourself. All this hassle for
what, you ask? What's the payoff? We'll
definitely get to it, but for now, just
to get a taste, recross the paths. This
is one of the very few ram spells that
actually work with this deck. I mean,
we're already heavily favored in Clash,
and the more you cast this, the more
unbeatable we become. But rest of the
juicy payoffs I will save till the end
because at this point, we should be
presenting our commander. If I wait any
longer, I might just forget to do it.
Essica, god of the tree, and the
backside, prismatic brit. And if you
haven't guessed already, she's not very
important to our game plan. I mean,
Esica is decent because even without
other legends, her mana ability is
somewhat helpful in such an impoverished
deck. And if you get the breathing room
to drop the bridge, it will generate
decent value, cheating terrifying land
cyclers onto the board. But yeah, most
fivecolor legends will probably do okay
here. Actually, Golos used to be at the
helm, but it got banned. Not sure why.
Probably because of this deck. I've also
seen similar lists run progenitis and
another one with Reaper King, but for
now, we're sticking with Esica. Now,
let's take a closer look at our
unnecessarily complicated land base. 15
land cyclers, three of each color. The
ones from Lord of the Rings are
absolutely brilliant, and they also keep
printing new cycling 2 options. So, we
have a few to choose from, but here is
what we're using right now. Also, 15
MDFCs, the ones that can enter untapped
for some life are premium, but the front
side is also relevant. We may need that
utility in a pinch. And for the real
lens, we can pretty much use anything
that has land types. 10 DS, 10 shocks,
10 trilands, surveillance, or even just
these, doesn't matter. 10 lands. So, a
total of 40 lands technically. But even
with all that cycling, we might still
struggle to hit our land drops. So,
we're also including a ton of card draw,
tutors, and recursion. Although, most of
our cards kind of do two things here.
So, it may be difficult to clearly
define which is which. Definitely don't
try to use them. Deck building templates
here. We're going by vibes, card draw,
and card selection. As you can see, for
a lot of these, we're basically
overpaying for effects just because
they're part of a bigger package or has
alternate costs. The bringers are
actually sweet for five mana recursion.
To be honest, we don't need that much
recursion, but just look at the mana
value on these. Oh, yes. Also, the green
ones here are more like life gain
spells. We need these because of how
slow our deck is, and it's really
freaking slow. So, yeah, we're going to
need a ton of removals and answers to be
able to keep up with the table. And by a
ton, I mean 21 pieces. If this feels
excessive, just remember you don't
always have to play them as removals.
They can also be Kantress, graveyard
hate, more recursion, or just big dumb
creatures. The board wipes are pretty
important though. Your opponents will
surely be developing while you fiddle
with yourself for the first few turns.
Blossomous Act and Vanquish the Horde
are all stars. Hour of Revelation is
really powerful, but the triple white
can cause some issues. And next up, we
have a few cards that are just big.
That's basically their qualification. If
they were the same card, but costed half
the mana, they'd all be cut. Personality
does not matter. Size is everything. And
you can tell I'm restraining hard to not
make some jokes right now, but this is
no place for comedy. This deck is very
serious. Let's start small. At seven
mana, Overlord of the Mistors, actually
a really powerful card that can help us
hold the fort early and late. Float Sam
and Jet Sam at eight mana. Normally,
we're just using the left side, but the
right can actually be quite impactful if
we draw this late. Afterlife from the
LOM is similar also at eight mana. We
have to be very careful with Delve here
because we use our graveyard for other
things like life gain. But this one does
work pretty well with her deck with all
the creatures we're dumping. And again,
late game, this can be a lot of power
for just three mana. Moving up to nine
mana, we have cavern horde dragon. I'm
usually casting this for five to six
mana, and it's excellent at that rate,
smacking your opponents while ramping us
into bigger, better things. 11 mana, the
pride of hog plate. Just a decent
defender that we can drop for cheap with
just one or two creatures on board. And
once in a while when the opportunity
arises, we get to smack someone and draw
15. Seems okay. Also at a level mana, we
have blood for the blood god. A lot of
our deck is instant speed. The cycling,
the removals, and alongside those
instance, we are holding on to this.
Waiting for our boardwalk to hit.
Doesn't resolve often, but when it does,
all the weight is worth it. Just like
edging of eternalities. Yeah, I've been
waiting for that one for a while. Yes.
12 mana. Scion of Draco.
doesn't actually do anything, but we can
cast it for two mana. Sure, why not? 13
mana, Emercle, the Promised End. Now,
this is a true late game. Even with the
way we're filling our graveyard, we
probably won't be getting Emmy below
nine mana, but when you get there, she
can win games all by herself. And
finally, at 16 mana, our biggest boy,
Draco, the ultimate payoff in this deck.
Draco will be a six mana 9 with no
upkeep to pay. This was probably Magic
Players collective wet dream in 2001.
And now we get to live it. And now that
you've seen the biggest boys, especially
Draco, we can finally look at the rest
of the payoff cards. And we evaluate
them with Draco in mind. Yes, we're just
going to assume we're always getting it.
Planeteer of Orthane to get Scry 2 every
turn and also force our opponents to
give us a card or we Draco them.
Reviving Vapor to dig for Draco and gain
16 life. Kaboom to reveal Draco and deal
16 damage. Soul Fire Eruption to deal 16
with Draco and cast it after. Pyromancy
to discard Draco and Vengeful Rebirth to
recur Draco for you guessed it 16 and 16
more damage. Heretic punishment milling
Draco for 16. Sar and Grim Nemesis
revealing Draco for 16. Draw 16 with
interpret the signs and make 16 blockers
with Alminster. And now we have the most
fascinating card in the deck. Aside from
Draco, of course, Psychic Battle. We'll
be choosing targets for all things all.
As long as the cards say is target, we
are in control. Equipments, auras,
removals, reanimation, even some extra
turn cards, we are taking them. Speaking
of extra turns, this deck falls firmly
in bracket one. But if you want to sneak
your way up, time shifter will take us
straight to bracket five, maybe higher.
And you think we're finished? No, we're
not. Remember how we barely have any
lands in the deck? Yeah, we're also
doing goblin char. After some cycling,
we'll be charging our opponents for 10
15 damage easily in the mid game and
double that in the late game. And there
you have it, the biggest deck in
commander and maybe all of magic.
Disclaimer, this deck is actually a bit
of a pain to play, but it does work and
can easily be one of the most unique
builds in any bracket one through
bracket 3 play group. This is Chin from
Next Level Commander. Normally, I try to
build decks that are functional and
unique, prioritizing the former. And
this mana value deck is probably as
wacky as I'll be going. But if this is
the kind of content you actually enjoy
seeing, please let me know in the
comments and subscribe so you don't miss
future content. Thanks and I'll see you
soon.